s 20 are going to have to hop the GP to
get out here what started as a retail
theft at a Wisconsin Department Store
quickly turned into a foot chase along
the highway after a getaway driver lost
control of his vehicle while leading
police on a high-speed
chase it all started on August 88th in
Glendale Wisconsin just north of
Milwaukee that's where 29-year-old Lil
Cherry gallion allegedly stole
$1300 worth of merchandise from Kohl's
security camera video shows gallion run
out of the store and make a break for a
nearby vehicle but as gallion runs to
the passenger side a squad car pulls up
dash camera video shows another angle of
gallion running out of the store before
that squad car
approaches
Department going trying
to video shows the cop car drive in
front of the suspect's vehicle in an
attempt to block it off but within
seconds the vehicle driven by
27-year-old suspect Robert hill crashes
into the
squad while still in the Kohl's parking
lot hill crashes the vehicle four times
into multiple squad
cars just hit both
squads hands show hands
hands
hands they just collided with the
squad
oh hit my spot hit another spot stop now
stop now Hill then leads police on a
lowspeed chase through the Bay Shore
mall parking lot before once again
colliding with a squad
car 768 behind we're going to be exiting
on the Bayshore Drive KSU 5215 going
through the Washington parking for male
black
drier he's got a black Tire going around
these key Stak speeds are
20 they're going to have to hop thep to
get off
here video shows these same moments from
another
angle
next Hill hops the curb as officers
follow officials follow Hill into a
nearby Bank parking lot where he crashes
once
again dash camera video captures these
same moments from multiple perspectives
as Hill jumps the curb and the chase
continues je we are 20 are going to have
to half the curve to get out
here H the curve going eastbound CR lot
going to go past C per fank we're in
Pursuit we're going to come out Pat
still in the bank lot still in the bank
clot 768 hop The Curve going eastbound
through with the lock going to go past
First Citizens Bank we're in Pursuit
we're going to come out past still in
the bank lot still in the bank
lot going through the tellers here back
through the parking lot of
H they going to go back westbound going
to come back out on
Bayshore okay we are Northbound on
Bayshore Drive passing Old again ASU
5215 wanted the retail theft speeds are
40 there's no traffic as Hill speeds
through the mall area he crashes again
into another
vehicle
multiple 1050 airbag deployment by Z
1050 airbag deployment after that Hill
exits the mall parking lot by hopping
yet another curb the chase continues as
he begins driving in the wrong lane of
traffic got to spin around but it's
still southbound in the Northbound Lanes
on Fort Washington Road drop that for
silver old dash camera video captures
the Chase from multiple different
officers
perspectives someone check on that car
it's a black sedan it's going to go
Southbound on for in the wrong Lanes of
travel south bound in the wrong Lanes of
travel
old L like we might be going east here
no we're going to go straight
through South he corrected southbound in
Washington passing South up for
pitard on the pit sou Lan passing
there's medium traffic here those
clear still self on the Northbound Lanes
looks like we might be going east here
nope we're going to go straight
through continuing South he corrected
southbound in the southbound Lanes
coming to a red light at the freeway
this is 778
calling went through two vehicles here
doesn't look like he struck either
continuing southbound still has a front
flat left tire now a highspeed Chase
along the highway Hill switches into the
correct Lane of traffic as a squad car
closely follows
anyone Che
on 784
stopped continuing southbound coming up
to back in the wrong Lanes of traffic
here up to a green
lights soub can I pit if I have a
chance take over C on for Washington
passing with to souer 40 lining up for a
p North Lane passing Mar there's traffic
here roads are clear and
dry turn back into correct Lanes of
travel southb on court in the correct
Lane coming up to Hampton work 50
mph coming upamp right now are we're
going to go west west video shows Hill
attempting to make a turn when he loses
control and crashes his vehicle into a
construction
site after crashing the car Hill hops
out of the driver's side and makes a
break for
it
police P
pursued
2 body camera video shows this foot
chase before Hill is ultimately caught
and
arrested heads Sho your
heads got one running cell
phone
stop get out of the
ground I'm
down
down back stop resisting anyone clear
the car yeah we got one guy back
there
meanwhile separate body camera video
shows gallion
arrest hey hey hey
hey come out come out exit the
car exit the car
how on the ground on the ground all the
way all the way okay
get hand if you want me to I hands
behind your hands behind your
back in addition to both arrests for
Hill and gallion 18-year-old valicity
McBride was also taken into custody
officials say she was stealing from the
back of the coal store all three now
face charges for felony retail theft
while Hill faces additional charges
including hidden run resisting an
officer and recklessly endangering
safety reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie